(vrombissement)
- Une dernière patrouille pour
s'assurer que plus personnen'est
Doug Watts et son coéquipier
ont passé plusieurs heures
sur les terres inondées de
cette petite communauté modeste
dans les terres de Floride.
De forts courants, des débris,
des contaminants et même
des aligators, il ne recommande
à personne de nager ici.
Pas très loin, des cadavres
ont été trouvés. Une majorité
des personnes tuées par Ian
seraient des aînés
qui se sont noyés.
Résidant de l'endroit,
Mike Fyers constate les dégâts.
Il a eu peur.
"Au prochain ouragan, dit-il,
je ne reste pas sur place."
À quelques kilomètres,
on assiste à un autre exemple
d'entraide.
- Wou-hou!
- Des banques alimentaires
distribuent eau et nourritur
aux sinistrés qui attendent
leur tour plusieurs heures.
"Je suis reconnaissant
d'être en vie", dit cet homme.
"Je dois nourrir mes enfants.
Je ne sais même pas dans
quel état se trouve ma maison."
Les résidents de W
peuvent difficilement
se déplacer. Toute l'eau tombée
au nord de l'État redescend
vers la t déborder
les rivières un peu
partout dans la région.
Dans les villes les plus
touchées par l'ouragan, les
opérations de secours continuent
donc. 5000 membres de la Garde
nationale ont été déployés
pour évacuer les sinistrés
encore coincés.
"Des écoles et des églises
peuvent les accueillir",
dit le responsable
des opérations à North Port.
En fin de journée, ils sont
encore des dizaines à monter
dans les camions militaires.
"Nous étions entourés d'eau
sans provision, dit-il.
On nous notre maison
finirait par être inondée."
Leur résilience à tous
a de quoi impressionner.
"Normal, nous répond-on ici,
nous sommes de la Floride.
On a l'habitude."
Ici Jean-Sébastien Cloutier,
Radio-Canada,
North Port, en Floride.